the Democratic National Convention is
officially underway and night one did
not disappoint thanks to heartfelt
speeches from Demi Lovato and First Lady
Michelle Obama we can do better every
one of us can make a difference first
the 23 year old opened up about living
with mental illness and got candid about
enacting change untreated mental illness
can lead to devastating consequences
including suicide substance abuse and
long-term medical issues I urge every
politician to support laws that will
provide access to better health care and
support for everyone then FLOTUS came
out in this election there is only one
person who i trust with that
responsibility only one person who i
believe is truly qualified to be
president of the united states and that
is our friend Hillary Clinton she looked
forward to the future as she praised
Hillary for president but also got
emotional looking back on her eight
years in the White House the story that
has brought me to the stage tonight the
story of generations of people who felt
the lash of bondage the shame of
servitude the sting of segregation but
who kept on striving and hoping and
doing what needed to be done so that's a
day I wake up every morning in a house
that was built by slaves Michelle's
speech not only moved the audience but
also her husband President Obama tweeted
incredible speech by an incredible woman
couldn't be more proud in our country
has been blessed to have her as FLOTUS I
love you Michelle
you